so we've come a long way with
smartphones and you could definitely see
that when i reviewed every single iphone
in a row that's ever been made 1 through
13. but this
this should be
very different because the question of
what exactly defines a google phone has
changed quite a bit over the years
they've been all over the place but
they've also come a long way in a
different way
[Music]
so what is a google phone first of all
well today the correct answer would be a
pixel of course right but if you ask the
same question anywhere from around 2010
to 2015 the correct answer would have
been
a nexus a nexus is a google phone or
maybe any number of google play editions
but if we're going all the way back to
the beginning which we are it started
with this
the g1 so the g1 was manufactured by htc
and this is going to be a key thing to
pay attention to throughout this whole
timeline because until the year 2016
google has never been the manufacturer
the hardware company that builds the
google phone google makes great software
and great services but absolutely has
never been a hardware company they've
just been out here making android so
before the g1 android was originally
built to be an alternate operating
system for digital cameras
still a great idea by the way uh but
eventually google bought android in
2005. i think andy rubin at some point
called it literally the best deal ever
but there was briefly a prototype called
the sooner that was never sold but was
manufactured also by htc based on their
excalibur and used to demonstrate and
test this new version of an open source
mobile operating system
and then by 2008 we had the t-mobile g1
i remember really wanting this phone but
i was on verizon and i was 15 so i
couldn't just switch for a phone that
looked cool but it did it looked so cool
it was really a different design from so
many of the other phones out at that
time it had a trackball in addition to
the touchscreen which wasn't that weird
because blackberries had those too but
there was also the end call sleep wake
button there was a dedicated camera
button with a state-of-the-art 3
megapixel camera on the back but also
there were these buttons down here on a
chin that's bent in at the bottom which
is very different and that sliding
mechanism for the keyboard which is
still super springy and very satisfying
was always pretty unique even at a time
where lots of phones had springs and
hinges and of course on top of all of
that it was running android version one
on 192 megabytes of ram and a 320 by 480
display now being different isn't always
necessarily good right this phone
definitely got mixed reviews when it
dropped you know the low contrast screen
wasn't amazing there was no headphone
jack so you needed an adapter for this
proprietary mini usb port to plug in
headphones but this google phone was all
about android it was all about the
software and that's what made it
different from the blackberries or palm
trios or even the original iphone that
was out at this time that's what the g1
was all about so this phone had to come
out for the rest of what we're talking
about today to even exist but what most
people think of when they think of the
first ever google phone
is this the nexus one so right off the
bat this phone was a flagship i remember
it was a huge deal that it launched with
a one gigahertz processor that was a
barrier we were approaching at the time
it had a relatively large 3.7 inch
display and a higher 800 by 480
resolution and beyond all the new power
in the big screen there is now
multi-touch capability so the most
memorable feature you might remember
about this phone was the live wallpaper
behind all your icons and new widgets i
feel like every video on this phone had
the live wallpaper with the moving
colors and you could just touch a bunch
of different spots and they'd pop up
oh and it had a trackball again so
clearly google liked that as much as i
did there were some other things too
like
the back popped off battery removable
this phone also launched back this early
with google goggles which let you id
things through the camera that's a long
time to be doing that and also it
launched with the android market which
was an early first version of what we
now know as google play store so a lot
of things happening on the nexus one but
i think really this is the phone that
set the tone for me from what i expect a
google phone to be which is a flagship a
very capable flagship phone but asterisk
this phone is again built
by htc you can see the little badge at
the bottom here and so at this point htc
is building plenty of other great phones
but they've also collaborated with
google on this one so we get an htc
build it's pretty dense it's made of
metal it also has a spot for a micro sd
card slot to expand memory alongside
that removable battery
there is some resemblance to some other
htc phones that came out around the time
and chief among them was the htc desire
but with some google specific
adjustments like the capacitive button
layout below the screen was just for
nexus one and the trackball which also
lit up as a notification light was just
for nexus one so this one was sick weird
fact though it was discontinued
completely after six months
you know didn't really get any promo
from carriers was kind of trying to be
sold online only and it was just over
after half a year so
then we moved on so what did we get
after nexus one
we got nexus s
and this one was made by samsung so this
launched right around the same time as
their first ever samsung galaxy s hence
the name so those phones were built
similarly but again this one was
customized a bit for the google
experience and so now that we have a
sequel this is the first time we're
really thinking about the question what
is a nexus what is a google phone
supposed to be there were also some
curious things about this phone like it
had a slightly curved four inch display
that wrapped a little bit i guess around
your face or felt more natural in the
hand sort of sure
it was also one of the first ever phones
with nfc which would of course be the
foundation later to android pay and it's
the first google phone with a selfie
camera it was a vga resolution selfie
camera but it was still a selfie camera
this phone launched with android
gingerbread which was one of the first
versions it was the first version to
have a darker aesthetic
not quite hollow but definitely shades
of the night mode we have today and a
screen off animation also one of the
coolest most memorable things about this
phone look like a crt tv turning off
it's the little things but really at
this point nexus
is the phone with the most
google
software it's the pure android phone so
it doesn't have any bloatware it doesn't
have any modifications doesn't have any
skin like you might find on the samsung
version or an htc or motorola phone it's
the google
software phone so the next year in 2011
we got the galaxy nexus so
there's an even more obvious collab
between google and samsung we all know
about galaxy s this was a nexus again
made by samsung so it's the galaxy nexus
and as a verizon customer this was the
first nexus i was able to get and it was
also the first and only phone i've ever
lined up outside of a store and waited
for then i proceeded to make eight
videos on it but again this was a really
interesting phone as a google phone so
it had a much larger 4.65 inch still
curved 720p hd oled display and it had a
better 5 megapixel rear camera on the
back with instant shutter it still had a
headphone jack and it still had an
easily removable battery remember those
days when you could just pop out the
battery and drop in another one two
seconds later and be at 100 but now as a
nexus this phone launches with stock
android 4.0 ice cream sandwich the holo
os the physical buttons are gone long
before the iphone dropped their home
button and android is now entirely doing
on-screen navigation and like i
mentioned this phone is in stores so i
got it out of verizon store now it still
wasn't a huge seller nexuses were still
for
android enthusiasts
but yeah i was in the thick of it i
remember i had custom roms
custom kernels on this phone i
overclocked this phone i was having a
good time the galaxy nexus
but things were about to change so i'm
going to skip the beloved nexus 7 tablet
and the not so beloved nexus q media
player that technically came up next
they were nexuses but they weren't
google phones there was also a motorola
zoom tablet that i loved back in the day
that was succeeded by a nexus 10 but the
next nexus phone
was the nexus 4. so now we've moved on
to a google phone made by lg so this
phone was interesting it sort of took a
step back from being a flagship on the
shelf of a carrier store and went back
to being a great deal that you could get
online so we have this unique flat glass
design with no camera bump and a super
unique dot pattern underneath that you
could see when the light hit it a
certain way it had a slot speaker around
the back which is an interesting choice
but at least you could cup your hand
around it and hear it better at the
front but of course now with this glass
design it becomes the first nexus that
supports wireless charging but the back
is no longer removable this phone
dropped for 299 which in 2012 yep was a
good deal although that was the base 8
gig model so you could spring for the
upgraded 16
roomy 16 gigs of memory for 349 bucks
um it was lacking lte at the time which
was a bit much but overall the phone was
pretty well liked so now what's a google
phone
uh a well-specced competitive stock
android phone for enthusiasts
i guess well nexus 5 was built by lg
again this time loosely based off of the
lg g2 but this was a design i really
liked it was understated had some
contrasting black and white hardware i
called it the panda phone because who
else did a white earpiece like this
nobody but honestly the rest of the
phone was pretty forgettable they got up
to a flagship spec again snapdragon 800
with two gigs of ram 1080p display but i
was pretty unimpressed by the camera it
did make hangouts the default text
messaging app but if you know anything
about google messaging apps
yeah that wouldn't last long i think
probably the most significant thing that
came from the nexus 5 was a little extra
focus on the stock google now launcher
so these phones have always shipped with
aosp which is android open source
project it's basically just a version of
android that you get when you download
it straight from google stock blank
nothing extra added but now google's
actually starting to add a little bit of
its own special sauce on top of android
when it ships it with a nexus phone so
this shipped with android 4.4 kitkat one
of the two candy themed collabs but the
launcher had google now built in where
you could swipe over from the home
screen and it would give you these cards
and the google assistant would show you
this information on the cards that it
predicted would be useful to you before
you would even ask for it so stuff like
the weather at a destination you're
about to fly to or the traffic on your
way to work before you leave in the
morning really smart stuff so nexus 5
was an uninspiring piece of hardware
pretty simple and basic
definitely was the beginning of seeing
some of google leaning into being a
smarter phone than your typical
smartphone
also shout out to the red version of
this guy that came out a few months
after launch that was so bright that it
literally over saturated pretty much
everyone's camera i remember it was
impossible to make this phone look the
actual red that it shipped on video
but it completed the trifecta of the
mkbhd edition smartphone colors so that
was very nice
okay here comes 2014
and here comes
shamu the most unnecessarily massive
nexus of all time
now
made by motorola
so okay at this point is there any theme
to who makes the nexus phone each year i
mean it feels like they just offer up a
two-year contract every time and see who
wants to sign allegedly they were really
close to working with huawei on this
year's phone but had to scrap it at the
last second so okay we got nexus 6 just
based loosely around the 2nd gen moto x
but just way bigger and it is huge it's
got a massive nearly 6 inch 1440p
display flanked by stereo front-facing
speakers and the bezels and you know we
have big screens nowadays but this was
also in the days of the 16x9 aspect
ratio so it's super wide too just huge
in the hand not to jump ahead too much
but nexus 6 is actually bigger and wider
than the pixel 6. so huge display huge
3200 milliamp hour battery with
motorola's turbo charging huge new 13
megapixel camera with a huge new ring
flash around it and huge new flagship
specs snapdragon 805 three gigs of ram
and up to 64 gigs of storage and android
5.0 lollipop but along with all these
insane specs
was an insane price for the time so
nexus 6 cost 649
for the base 32 gig version and a
whopping 700 bucks for the 64. so it was
not only big but it had the biggest
price tag of any google phone yet
especially coming off the back of the
more competitive nexus 4 and 5. fun fact
the internal code name of this phone
when they were developing it shamu
the orca the whale
see everyone knew it was big but maybe
the most sneaky important feature of the
nexus 6
came in the camera so this was the first
ever google phone to launch with hdr
plus
didn't seem like a huge deal at the time
it was just maybe one more feature in
the camera but it was combining multiple
frames all together in a quick shot to
bring in more dynamic range and
notoriously took a lot of processing
power so hdr plus was just an option
that you had to turn on to get that
extra latitude but that right there
that was an inflection point for
smartphone cameras in general i mean
nowadays if you don't have hdr you're
not really doing it right but just the
fact that we take for granted now one
single shutter press
information from several different
frames all get processed and smartly
blended together
big moment there so then nexus 9 you
were great
nexus player
definitely not great but then in 2015 we
got two new nexus phones at once we got
the 5x made by lg
and the nexus 6p
made by huawei
okay so the nexus 5x as the name
suggests was a bit of an upgrade from
the nexus 5. it added a fingerprint
reader on the back updated specs bigger
battery switched to usb type c all the
classics it did also have boot loop
issues that thankfully never affected
mine but that phone was 379
then at the same time we get this all
metal jacket nexus 6p p for premium
probably but this was an all metal build
with a camera visor at the top it had
the flat sides which we still know today
as premium the ridged power button the
front-facing speakers and the highest
end chip and hdr got even better this
one had a stellar camera 6p was pretty
universally praised as literally one of
the best if not the best android phones
on the planet this one sold for 4.99 so
google you just made
two different
nexuses at the same time nexuses
nexi you made two of them at once right
one of them cheaper one of them more
expensive one of them budget one of them
contender for phone of the year very
premium
and so this is usually what you see from
companies that are trying to offer
two different options for two different
customers it's what you get while you're
trying to appeal to a broader variety of
the masses which is an interesting move
and then that's the last we ever saw of
nexus so enter google pixel
i just want to say as a video enthusiast
i love the word pixel as a name for a
phone but that is a new name so we've
had nexus and nexus up until this point
we could think of as the google software
phone right we had all the samsungs and
htc's and motorolas and huawei's of the
world making all their own phones but
the google version with the nexus name
would be stock android quick updates
straight from google
there was also a brief stint of google
play edition phones in 2013 to 2014 that
combined the hardware of the best phones
in the world
with google's stock software does anyone
else remember these i love these phones
there was a google play edition samsung
galaxy s4
it was amazing there was a sony xperia z
ultra there was a google play edition
htc one m8 honestly some of the best
phones ever
but this is a brand new thing this is
pixel it's not nexus so why the rebrand
why the new name well there's a bunch of
different correct answers i think to
this but basically this is the first
phone that's designed and built
by google so there's your google logo
down there it's the first iteration of
this new two-tone design i mean
internally they still had some help but
this would be considered the first real
google phone
but also a big part of what makes pixel
next level is how they really started
leaning into it being a particularly
smart smartphone so it already had that
google launcher and the clean look but
we're drifting further away from aosp
this is not the exact version of android
you'd get straight from google this is
now like the google skin on top of
android so it's the first android phone
with the google assistant built in and
it's got the camera again taking pretty
big leaps forward thanks to hdr plus
continuing to get better and i just
remember seeing this announcement and
getting really optimistic about the
future of competition because
surely if we have the iphones of the
world where apple controls the hardware
the software the chip the whole
everything was made by apple to work
perfectly together
then surely this is the beginning of
google doing their best version of the
same thing you know so google pixel 2
i think
was peak pixel and that's at least in
two ways right with that camera
and with that two-tone design i love a
good panda phone already or stormtrooper
whatever you want to call it we saw
hints of this with the nexus 6p but
google is now just full-on embracing the
two different finishes on the back by
contrasting them with black and white
and then the colored power button wow
what a great idea for just a little
splash of color a little accent on the
side but there were a few other notable
things here they got rid of the
headphone jack they did have some blue
shift display controversy on the xl
version which used the new lg p led and
i even made a video a few months after
launch about why i don't use the pixel
anymore because of slowing down issues
with the software over time but what the
pixel 2 was really famous for
was this single camera so it had a new
12.2 megapixel sensor in there and
featured the latest and greatest from
google's camera app their hdr plus and
their multi-fame processing
and this phone just kicked out
incredible photos it leapfrogged over
everything else out it had excellent
detail sharpness dynamic range shutter
speed focus everything and the videos it
took weren't even that good but the
photos were just so
good that this
was basically universally praised when
it came out as the best smartphone
camera of all time but also at this
point i think it's worth talking about
sales so this one comes out google's
selling three to five million pixels per
year which is nice right but at the same
time you know apple selling 200 million
phones a year samsung selling 300
million phones a year so even with this
incredible world-class camera great
reviews enthusiasts loving it great
software
it's not a lot of people buying it so
pixel 3 comes out in 2018 and every bit
of it feels just like a refinement on
the pixel 2 which is great for people
who love the pixel 2 but the minor
improvement alone probably isn't going
to spike sales as you can imagine and
there's also regular and an xl version
of every pixel since the first one but
this one's xl came with a super duper
alpha omega bathtub notch up at the top
at this point i think we can say it's
the deepest notch we've ever seen in a
phone it did have both a regular and
ultra wide selfie camera up at the front
on either side of the earpiece
front-facing speaker so
honestly i loved that extra ultra wide
selfie camera on the xl
but nobody really loved the notch
there was an old google tweet basically
trying to justify it by saying oh don't
worry the notch to display ratio is
actually less than many of our top
competitors it's like yeah that's
probably true but also so would this
notch but that doesn't make it good
either way aside from that minor tweaks
overall refinement of the build
materials ip68 water resistance finally
up from ip67 wireless charging gets
added here
night sight is added to the camera app
but basically the same revolutionary
camera as last year and overall pretty
solid update doesn't really move the
needle you know it did move the needle
though
the pixel 3 a
this phone
shifted things for google so halfway
through 2019 at google i o they
announced a budget version of the pixel
it's a 3a and a 3a xl starting at 399
which is half the price that the pixel 3
started at
so it has all the same software smarts
all the stuff that made pixel
enthusiasts love the phones but made a
budget version with a lower powered
internals polycarbonate instead of metal
and glass still has great battery life
in the same world-class camera that put
the pixel on the map for so many people
and it was a hit basically from the
moment this phone was released it was
most of the pixel sales
and so there's some upside and some
downside to this level of visibility the
upside obviously is there's now more
people seeing and using these phones and
google assistant and all this great
stuff and the camera but
now the most successful version of this
product
is the cheap one
which means that when people think of
what is a google phone what is a pixel
they think of it as the cheap phone that
takes good pictures they're not thinking
of the fast one or the high-end one
it's the cheap phone with the good
pictures pixel 4 came out after that and
honestly felt like a slight misstep it
launched again starting at 800 bucks
they're trying the flagship thing again
but there were a bunch of quirky weird
features that either didn't really make
sense or didn't pan out the way google
was probably hoping now again it had the
same a plus camera as the pixel 2
but it's been two years now so the rest
of the world is starting to catch up and
it's not so unanimous anymore and it was
a bit short on battery life and with the
addition of a second rear camera for the
first time they chose a telephoto
instead of a much more popular and
useful ultra wide even though they
talked a lot about the software super
res zoom and not needing a telephoto
anyway it was the solely radar array up
front that was an interesting idea with
a ton of cool demos and other products
but really turned out to draw a lot of
power and ultimately not have the
functionality in a phone that people
were looking for and it would get mixed
in a year so pixel 4 stepped back from
being one of the best phones out period
to being
genuinely pretty hard to recommend i
mean not a lot of people bought this
phone the sales figures say there was
about 2 million sales of pixel 4 in the
first six months
interestingly my review of the pixel 4
got
4.8 million views in the first six
months so
a lot of attention
just not a lot of people buying the
phone
and that's until pixel 4a came out so
naturally google followed up the
successful pixel 3a budget king with a
pixel 4a and they followed the same
formula with a lot of the same stuff
that people liked about the 3a same
camera again polycarbonate two-tone
design but this year the materials were
even better a little more textured
polycarbonate the screen was fantastic
especially for the price
they crushed it plus they even lowered
the price to start at 349 so to no one's
surprise following the same formula
got them a lot of people to really love
pixel 4a so okay at this point it feels
like google sort of settled into
something with the pixel right got pixel
3 pixel 3a pixel 4 pixel 4a
disappointing flagship
smash hit budget phone disappointing
flagship smash hit budget phone
and so if you keep going down this path
you continue to cement pixel as a budget
phone
maybe the rest of it kind of fades into
obscurity and it even kind of felt like
the design was slowly getting more
generic and plain
the two-tone is kind of gone
even the colored power button is a bit
more muted it's succumbed to the
pressures of the industry the back
fingerprint reader is gone the headphone
jack is gone so this google phone this
this pixel has basically just become uh
not that impressive
hardware wise but really incredible like
silo for google to demonstrate all of
their machine learning and their
software and ai
and that's not something that's going to
sell a whole ton i mean enthusiasts will
love it
but it doesn't even let them reach their
max potential with that either they're a
little limited by whatever the latest
off-the-shelf qualcomm chip is capable
of or designed for
so this
spoiler alert is right around when they
started making some serious progress on
something new in the background so this
is why pixel 5 and 5a felt kind of like
placeholder phones pixel 5 here is a 700
flagship so relatively normal price but
there's no xl version just one size
there's no higher capacity storage
versions just a single 128 gig
non-expandable spec
snapdragon 765 g just an off-the-shelf
upper mid-range chip
that's it it's just
it's here it's a phone it's like the
it's like the blank canvas
2020 of phones like oh you've got a
corner cut out for the selfie camera so
does everybody else it's got wireless
charging it's got no headphone jack it's
like we've seen this shell before
well maybe not with the
soft touch on top of metal but inside
is where all that software magic is
still happening that all the enthusiasts
who love the pixel still care deeply
about all that's still in there so
that's how most reviews including my own
looked at the pixel 5. decent if
underwhelming hardware but android 11 is
better than ever google assistant is
improving on these incredibly useful
pixel exclusive features on top of aosp
like assistant screening spam calls and
it's once again basically the same
camera stack as the pixel 2 but
computational photography still brings
out the best of this hardware and it is
still one of the best photo takers in
the industry then pixel 5a drops almost
a year later again with one spec and one
size and it is
very very very very very similar to the
pixel 4a 5g from the year before but
predictably people like a big screen and
a big battery and a big camera performer
for a low price so this was again the
winner but this whole time kind of in
the background
some of it because there's always rumors
of things in the tech industry but some
of it because it was truly new was
rumors of google working on a phone that
is even more of a google phone than
before and google's pretty bad at
containing leaks so a lot of that stuff
got out and they just straight up
confirmed it and so after many teasers
and pre-released information and leaks
it finally arrived 2021's pixel 6.
this is now the apex of being the most
google phone ever
finally i actually remember being in
some meetings and briefings with some
google employees before this phone came
out they're showing it to me and they
all kind of have this smirk on their
face like yeah we finally did it we
really made a google phone this time
because now this one has a google design
google software and a google designed
chip called tensor
and so kind of like how the name changed
from nexus to pixel when they finally
started doing the design themselves
they've definitely changed up the design
here with this camera bar at this
beginning of them designing their own
silicon and the benefits of the new
silicon with the dedicated machine
learning accelerators has been very real
both with the photo and video processing
now and speech to text things like that
the rest of the phone is also now pretty
high end across the board mostly not
quite bleeding edge but you add the
larger higher resolution high refresh
rate displays faster charging more ram
and a suite of all new much larger
camera sensors featuring a massive main
sensor so then it does start to feel
like a pretty big upgrade the most
impressive thing about this phone though
might just be how much effort google now
is putting in to making sure the world
knows that this is a flagship i mean all
the advertising spend all the effort
getting this in front of people's eyes
this is a flagship and it's a google
flagship and it's a good one that's what
they want us all to think
now
from some conversations i've had with
people at google
they were working on tensor for a long
time and they actually wanted to have
this out earlier they're actually
planning
on pixel 5 being the first phone
with tensor
but then with covid and supply chain
issues and a bunch of things getting in
the way at the last second they kind of
had to bail on that but they still
wanted to drop a new phone so they just
put a snapdragon 765 g in it
shipped it called it a day
and kept putting their heads down for
pixel 6. so it is out now and while
they're definitely trying to be flagship
flagship flagship
they're also definitely not going to shy
away from the proven formula of making a
pixel 6a i would totally expect to see
that sometime soon probably going to
look a lot like this but cheaper
materials it'll come out it'll probably
also do really well but i think now if
you revisit the question one last time
of what is a google phone
we see google trying to push an answer
on us which is
it's a flagship phone it's genuine
option and it's got a lot of good stuff
and that's where we stand today 13 years
of google
trying to make a smartphone
and going from the g1 to the nexus one
to the pixel one
and the merging from uh from defining a
google phone as the phone made by
another manufacturer with the google
software on it alongside another version
that has some skin
to being a google play editions to being
the nexus
designed by google
all the way up now to the pixel where
all the way top to bottom you pretty
much have google stuff so the tensor
phone
is the beginning of the new definition
looking forward
for what is a google phone
and we'll continue to see that evolve
over time from here either way that's
pretty much it definitely let me know
what other lines of phones should i look
at there's a lot of other options
there's the galaxy s line there's the
oneplus line a bunch of others leave it
in the comments section below under that
like button thanks for watching thanks
for subscribing
catch you in the next one
peace